juin 1959 le royal britannia accostent à
quelques mètres de lécluse de
saint-lambert sous le pont
jacques-cartier à la réalisation de ce
projet grandiose
la reine elizabeth ii et le président
américain dwight eisenhower ouvre
officiellement la voie maritime du saint
laurent
je suis très heureux de me trouver
retrouvait amusez-vous de britannia lève
l'entrée s'aventure dans la toute
nouvelle route maritime qui fait plus de
3700 km de long la largeur de l'océan
atlantique
ça a permis à des bateaux océaniques les
deux gros bateaux en somme de pouvoir
passer directement vers les grands lacs
du fleuve saint-laurent où l'un vers des
grands lacs vers le fleuve se lance sans
s'arrêter par montréal
les cargos océanie peuvent dorénavant
naviguer jusqu'à toronto
ils peuvent même franchir les chutes du
niagara et atteindre les ports
américains des grands lacs a été une des
raisons pas la seule mais une des
raisons pour laquelle toronto est
devenue une ville qui a pris de plus en
plus d'importance dans le canada est
détrôné montréal comme métropole du
canada dans la région de montréal il
faut littéralement soulevé les paons en
ontario l'enchaînement de canaux et des
cluses doit permettre au navire de
grimper des 180 mètres de dénivellation
qu'il y ait entre le niveau de la mer et
celui du lac supérieur l'équivalent d'un
immeuble de 60 étages au nom du progrès
des dizaines de villages et des
centaines de fermes de l'ontario sont
inondées
quelques bâtiments seront déplacés mais
la plupart repose maintenant au fond du
saint laurent
soixante ans plus tard la concurrence
des ports de la côte est est de plus en
plus féroce les états de new york ou de
la virginie peuvent accueillir les super
cargo qui sillonnent l'océan
par contre ces nouveaux monstres de la
mer le peuvent s'aventurer dans
l'étroite voie maritime du saint-laurent
ici vincent maisonneuve rase au canada
montréal
[Musique]